Effectivement, aujourd'hui, nous célébrons la fête des pères en France.
Et donc, ça va être pour moi l'occasion de prier pour les pères de famille dans notre église,
pour les enfants aussi, et pour la prédication qui va suivre.
Donc, je vous invite à courber la tête dans la prière pour prier pour ces sujets.
Seigneur, nous te remercions pour les familles dans notre assemblée.
Nous te remercions pour ce modèle que tu as voulu, que tu as créé,
ce modèle de la famille avec un père, une mère et des enfants.
C'est évidemment le seul modèle valable, celui qui porte les fruits qui sont bons pour une famille.
Et nous te prions, Seigneur, que nous puissions persévérer dans ce modèle que tu nous as laissé,
qui est inscrit dans ta création et dans ta parole.
Avec toutes les attaques que la famille peut connaître aujourd'hui, en particulier dans nos sociétés occidentales,
nous te prions, Seigneur, que nous tenions fermes, que nous tenions bons dans nos convictions.
Que tu puisses encourager tous les pères de famille dans notre assemblée,
dans leurs responsabilités, dans la mission que tu leur as accordée, Seigneur,
qu'ils puissent être fidèles dans l'enseignement spirituel de leur famille,
de leur épouse, de leurs enfants.
C'est un marathon, Seigneur, et c'est souvent difficile.
Nous le savons, nous le confessons.
Nous te supplions pour ton aide, Seigneur.
Nous prions pour que la fidélité des pères de famille dans notre Église
porte des fruits dans la vie de leurs enfants, en particulier.
Que tu puisses les utiliser pour la conversion de leurs enfants.
Te prions pour eux, en particulier ce matin,
que l'enseignement qu'ils recevront puisse porter des fruits dans leur vie.
Ton évangile est compréhensible par les plus jeunes, Seigneur,
avec des mots adaptés.
Et tu peux sauver à n'importe quel âge un être humain, Seigneur.
Et nous te supplions pour que tu puisses faire cela,
à travers la fidélité des familles, à travers la fidélité des enseignants,
dans l'école du dimanche,
que tu puisses gagner des âmes, Seigneur,
parmi les plus jeunes dans notre assemblée.
Seigneur, nous nous approchons avec humilité de ta parole, désormais.
Te louons pour cette première partie de culte.
Nous avons conscience, en nous approchant de ta parole, Seigneur,
de nos nombreux manquements,
dans tous les domaines de notre vie,
qui doivent être soumis à ta volonté.
C'est pourquoi, Seigneur, nous te prions,
que tu nous assistes,
que tu utilises le prédicateur,
malgré ses faiblesses,
et que tu agisses en chacun de nous, ici présents,
pour que ta parole prenne racine en nous,
et que le malin ne vienne pas aussitôt l'arracher.
Garde-nous, Seigneur,
dans la vérité et dans l'obéissance.
Au nom de Jésus-Christ. Amen.
Je laisse les enfants ou l'enfant partir.
Pendant ce temps, vous pouvez ouvrir vos Bibles
dans l'Épitre de Jacques,
au premier chapitre, verset 9.
Ce matin, nous allons poursuivre l'étude de cet Épitre.
Comme Loïc l'a rappelé,
il fait des prédications suivies dans l'Épitre aux Hébreux,
moi-même dans Jacques,
et Stéphane dans Ézéchiel.
Voilà.
C'est trompé de prophète.
Donc, comme la dernière prédication dans ce texte de Jacques
remonte à un bon moment déjà,
et qu'il y a même plusieurs d'entre vous
qui n'étaient pas présents lorsque elle a été faite,
je vous propose de commencer par nous rafraîchir un peu la mémoire
sur le contexte global de cette lettre, rapidement,
et puis aussi sur ce que nous avons médité
dans les deux premières prédications,
puisqu'il y a un lien avec ce que nous allons étudier aujourd'hui.
Donc, l'auteur de cette lettre, vous l'aurez deviné, c'est Jacques.
Il y a plusieurs Jacques dans la parole,
et celui qui a écrit cet Épitre, c'est le demi-frère de Jésus.
Et il l'a écrit à destination de plusieurs assemblées
dont les membres étaient majoritairement d'origine juive.
Et c'est donc ce que l'on appelle une Épitre catholique.
C'est même parfois écrit, désigné comme ça,
dans les Bibles un peu anciennes.
Épitre catholique de Jacques.
Alors, ça veut tout simplement dire qu'elle n'était pas destinée
à être lue par une assemblée en particulier,
comme l'Épitre aux Romains ou aux Corinthiens, par exemple,
mais qu'elle était destinée à circuler
entre plusieurs églises locales d'une même région
et à être lue,
et à adresser des problèmes généraux, communs,
à toutes ces églises locales.
Et c'est donc pour ça, en partie,
que les sujets que Jacques aborde dans sa lettre,
ils sont très différents, très divers,
et ils sont universels aussi.
Parce qu'ils concernent tous les chrétiens,
peu importe leur contexte historique
ou géographique particulier.
Aussi bien dans le fond que dans la forme,
et c'est particulièrement vrai pour le texte
que nous allons étudier aujourd'hui,
cette lettre ressemble beaucoup
aux écrits de sagesse de l'Ancien Testament,
comme Proverbe ou Ecclésiaste,
et aussi aux enseignements du Christ lui-même.
On sent vraiment, dans cette lettre,
que Jacques est influencé par les enseignements de Jésus.
C'est normal, il l'a beaucoup côtoyé, entendu.
Son style d'écriture, il est presque oral.
Il n'écrit pas du tout comme Paul le fait souvent,
avec un développement très travaillé,
beaucoup de transitions travaillées, elles aussi.
Le style de Jacques, il est assez simple,
il est direct,
et le fond, lui, il est très pratique
et très pastoral.
Elle est en effet, cette lettre,
remplie d'exhortations pratiques
sur des sujets, je l'ai dit,
très divers de la vie quotidienne du chrétien.
Pour la simple et bonne raison
que l'objectif du cœur de Jacques,
qui est un cœur pastoral,
c'est d'exhorter ses brebis
à mettre en pratique leur foi.
Pour lui, la foi chrétienne,
c'est une foi vivante.
Pour lui et pour tous les autres apôtres
et tous les chrétiens.
Cette foi vivante,
elle doit nécessairement se traduire en actes.
Et c'est tellement important à ses yeux
qu'il ira jusqu'à écrire ce verset bien connu,
surtout parmi les protestants,
qui a même fait trébucher Luther
dans sa compréhension.
Et ce verset qui a lui seul
peut résumer toute cette lettre,
l'homme est justifié par les œuvres
et non par la foi seulement.
Alors ça nous fait un peu hérisser les poils
à nous protestants.
Nous reviendrons sur ce verset
en temps voulu, évidemment.
Mais ce que ça veut dire en substance,
c'est que la foi authentique,
celle qui justifie en Christ,
elle porte forcément du fruit
dans tous les domaines de notre vie.
Le chrétien ne peut pas se contenter
de dire je crois.
Il doit aussi s'engager à faire.
Voilà le thème central de cette lettre
qui explique que son contenu
soit si semblable aux proverbes,
très pratiques,
et aux enseignements pratiques du Christ,
parce que Jacques souhaite
qu'aucun domaine de notre vie quotidienne
ne reste insoumis à la volonté de Dieu.
Souvent, ce qu'écrit Jacques dans sa lettre,
c'est simple à comprendre,
du moins en surface.
Et pourtant,
certaines de ses exhortations
les plus simples à comprendre
sont les plus dures à mettre en pratique.
Il est parfois,
vous le savez,
plus facile de croire
et d'affirmer des doctrines complexes
comme la prédestination des élus de Dieu,
par exemple,
que de tenir sa langue
lorsque c'est nécessaire,
ou de se réjouir dans la pauvreté.
C'est pourquoi cet épître
est évidemment digne de notre intérêt,
que nous ne devons pas survoler
ces exhortations pratiques
en apparence simple,
en apparence évidente,
parce que même si elles peuvent l'être parfois,
la dureté de notre cœur
nécessite que nous nous y arrêtions,
que nous nous laissions sonder
et confronter si nécessaire
par le Saint-Esprit
afin de travailler à notre sanctification.
Et donc, le premier thème
que nous avons abordé
des versets 1 à 4,
c'était
la persévérance du chrétien
dans les épreuves de sa vie.
Les destinataires directs
de cette lettre de Jacques,
ils étaient persécutés
à cause de leur foi en Christ,
que ce soit par les Romains
ou par les Juifs.
Et donc,
il est logique que Jacques
commence sa lettre
en les encourageant
à persévérer dans la foi,
malgré cette opposition dure
qu'ils vivent de toutes parts.
Il les encourage comment ?
Eh bien,
en leur exposant tous les bénéfices
qu'il y a à persévérer
dans l'épreuve.
Et le plus grand de ces bénéfices
étant qu'à travers elles,
à travers ces épreuves,
Dieu les sanctifie,
ses frères et sœurs,
à l'image du Christ,
pour les préparer
à la vie éternelle.
Pour les chrétiens,
les épreuves ne sont pas insensées,
elles ne nous arrivent
jamais au hasard.
Mais elles sont voulues,
ordonnées,
décidées et utilisées par Dieu
comme un formidable outil
de sanctification.
Elles ont un sens,
une utilité,
un but.
Elles font partie intégrante
de la vie chrétienne.
Elles ne sont pas
une anomalie
comme on peut l'entendre souvent.
Et si l'épreuve en elle-même,
elle peut certes être terrible,
personne ne nie cela,
extrêmement difficile à supporter,
ce qui nous encourage,
ce qui nous fait persévérer
malgré tout,
c'est l'issue forcément favorable
que Dieu a promis
de donner à cette épreuve.
Peut-être dans cette vie,
mais assurément dans l'éternité.
Un jour,
c'est certain,
Jésus-Christ essuera nos larmes,
il nous consolera lui-même,
il guérira à jamais
les blessures de nos âmes.
Si du moins,
comme le dit l'apôtre Paul,
nous demeurons fondés
et inébranlables dans la foi,
sans nous détourner
de l'espérance de l'Évangile
que nous avons entendu.
Et c'est exactement pour cela,
pour que nous ne baissions pas les bras
malgré les épreuves,
que Jacques nous encourage
dans ses premiers versets
à persévérer coûte que coûte,
sachant aussi,
quand il dit cela,
que Dieu a promis
de nous soutenir dans l'épreuve.
C'est la première grande vérité
sur laquelle nous avons médité
dans ses versets 1 à 4.
Et nous avons donc poursuivi
avec les versets 5 à 8,
en méditant cette fois-ci
sur ce que Jacques nous apprend
sur la prière efficace.
Car ici, Jacques semble faire
une transition directe
entre cette difficulté
à persévérer dans les épreuves
et la nécessité de prier.
Nous ne pouvons pas tenir bon
dans la vie chrétienne
sans prier,
en particulier dans l'épreuve.
Le pasteur Abel nous l'a rappelé
il y a quelques dimanches
dans son serment sur Gethsémane,
pour le chrétien.
La prière est notre oxygène.
Mais prier correctement
et donc efficacement,
eh bien, ça ne s'improvise pas.
Et donc, nous avons relevé
trois marqueurs essentiels
d'une prière efficace
qui sont,
premièrement,
le dessinateur
de nos prières.
Le seul vrai Dieu trinitaire.
Si nous adressons nos prières
à quelqu'un d'autre,
elles ne trouveront jamais
de réponse.
l'objet de nos prières
qui doit toujours être nourri
par les intérêts
du royaume de Dieu.
Et finalement,
la troisième caractéristique,
la disposition de notre cœur
dans la prière.
Nous devons prier avec foi,
c'est-à-dire sans avoir
un cœur double,
un cœur partagé
qui doute de Dieu.
On voit donc clairement
que dès le début de sa lettre,
Jacques s'intéresse
aux manifestations extérieures
de la vie intérieure.
du croyant.
Il fait tout
pour nous encourager
à pratiquer notre foi,
à mener une vie
qui soit cohérente
avec notre profession de foi,
à mener des vies
qui glorifient le Seigneur,
qui brillent vraiment
dans les ténèbres de ce monde,
même dans les circonstances
et les tentations
les plus difficiles.
Nous avons donc parlé
des épreuves,
nous avons parlé
de la prière
et aujourd'hui,
dans les versets 9 à 11,
nous allons parler
d'un sujet
très souvent abordé
dans les Écritures,
souvent tabou
pour les Français,
nous allons parler
d'argent.
Comment considérer
les richesses
de ce monde
en tant que chrétien ?
Comment se satisfaire
d'avoir peu
ou rester humble
lorsqu'on possède beaucoup ?
Peut-on être riche
et chrétien ?
Ou est-ce que les richesses
sont intrinsèquement mauvaises ?
Est-ce qu'être riche,
c'est mal
aux yeux de Dieu ?
A l'inverse,
est-ce que la pauvreté
serait une vertu chrétienne ?
Et est-ce que le pauvre
serait supérieur
aux riches
devant Dieu ?
Toutes ces questions,
nous les aborderons
dans cette prédication,
mais la question principale
que nous allons nous poser
face à ce texte,
c'est la suivante.
En tant que chrétien,
riche ou pauvre,
comment préserver mon âme
face aux richesses
de ce monde ?
En tant que chrétien,
riche ou pauvre,
comment préserver mon âme
face aux richesses
de ce monde ?
L'enjeu de cette exhortation
que Jacques adresse
dans ses versets,
elle va bien plus loin
que simplement dire
« Ne te plains pas
d'être pauvre,
ne te vante pas
d'être riche ».
L'enjeu ici
est profondément spirituel,
c'est notre âme
qui est concernée
par cette exhortation,
c'est son salut
qui est en jeu
comme nous allons le voir.
Je disais en introduction
que Jacques fait
très peu de transition
entre les divers sujets
de sa lettre
et ça ne loupe pas ici
puisque nous passons
directement du thème
de la prière
à celui des richesses.
Toutefois,
je pense que
sans faire dire
au texte
ce qu'il ne dit pas,
sans aller trop loin,
nous pouvons voir un lien
entre ces trois premiers thèmes.
Je le disais,
le chrétien ne peut
persévérer dans l'épreuve
s'il ne prie pas
avec un cœur sincère
et confiant devant Dieu.
C'est la première transition
que nous avons fait
entre les versets 4 et 5.
Et la transition
que nous pouvons faire ici
entre les versets 8 et 9,
c'est que le chrétien
ne peut pas garder son âme
face au manque
ou à l'abondance
de richesses
s'il n'a pas ce même cœur
sincèrement confiant
et entièrement
attaché à Dieu.
Ce même cœur
qui est nécessaire
pour prier avec foi
est nécessaire
pour préserver notre âme
face aux richesses terrestres.
Je le redis,
l'enjeu de l'exhortation
de Jacques ici,
c'est le salut
et la bonne santé
de notre âme.
Et la source
d'une mauvaise attitude
face aux richesses,
comme bien souvent,
c'est un cœur hypocrite,
un cœur qui est partagé
entre le monde
et Dieu.
En effet,
l'homme dont le cœur
est partagé
ou, selon la traduction,
l'homme au cœur double
dont il est question
au verset 8,
est exactement celui
qui est concerné
par cette exhortation
sur les richesses.
Un tel homme
est sans cesse
tiraillé entre les cieux
et le monde.
Il ne sait pas
dans quelle direction marcher.
Il ne sait pas vraiment
ce qu'il veut.
Son cœur est double
parce qu'un jour
il désire les choses du monde,
l'admiration des hommes,
l'argent,
la gloire,
la prospérité
à tout prix
et le lendemain
il se consacre à nouveau
à Dieu
et marche
dans la sainteté
pendant quelques jours,
quelques semaines
avant de rebasculer
de l'autre côté.
Pourquoi cela arrive ?
Eh bien,
parce que les affections
de son cœur
sont partagées
entre Dieu
et le monde.
Parce que sa prospérité
ici-bas compte
bien trop souvent
plus à ses yeux
que la prospérité
éternelle de son âme.
Et c'est dans un tel cœur
partagé entre les cieux
et la terre,
entre Dieu
et le monde,
que les tentations
liées à l'argent
prennent racine.
L'argent est un thème
qui revient très souvent
dans les Écritures.
Jésus a beaucoup enseigné
sur l'argent
lors de son ministère terrestre,
notamment pour nous mettre
en garde contre les risques
que les richesses comportent
pour notre âme.
On peut penser évidemment
à cette discussion
bien connue
avec le jeune homme riche
dont le cœur
était tellement
devenu attaché
à ses nombreux biens
qu'il n'était plus capable
de les abandonner
pour suivre Jésus.
Et c'est face
à cette réaction
du jeune homme riche
que Jésus enseigna
à ses disciples
la chose suivante.
Je vous le dis en vérité,
un riche entrera difficilement
dans le royaume des cieux.
Je vous le dis encore,
il est plus facile
à un chameau
de passer par le trou
d'une aiguille
qu'à un riche
d'entrer dans le royaume
de Dieu.
Si Jésus-Christ
a autant parlé d'argent,
ce n'est pas parce
qu'il était un communiste
convaincu
qui luttait
contre le grand capitalisme,
mais plutôt parce que
personne ne savait
aussi bien que lui
à quel point l'argent
est un révélateur
de notre état
de santé spirituelle.
Un des passages
les plus explicites
dans la parole
à ce sujet
se trouve dans,
évidemment,
un des enseignements
du Christ
dans le fameux
serment sur la montagne.
Nous connaissons
presque tous ici
les béatitudes
qui ouvrent ce serment
qui en réalité
est un serment très long
dans lequel Jésus parle
à plusieurs reprises
des richesses
de ce monde.
Et le passage
qui nous intéresse
ce matin
se trouve en Matthieu 6
à partir du verset 19.
Nous allons lire
les versets 19
à 21
et terminer
par le verset 24.
Matthieu 6,
19 à 21,
puis 24.
Ne vous amassez pas
des trésors
sur la terre
où la teigne
et la rouille
détruisent
et où les voleurs
persent et dérobent,
mais amassez-vous
des trésors
dans le ciel
où la teigne
et la rouille
ne détruisent point
et où les voleurs
ne percent
ni ne dérobent.
Car là où est ton trésor,
là aussi
sera ton cœur.
Nul ne peut servir
de maître
car où il haïra
l'un
et aimera l'autre
ou il s'attachera
à l'un
et méprisera l'autre.
Vous ne pouvez servir
Dieu
et maman.
Comprenez-vous
l'enjeu
que Christ présente ici ?
Il commence
par faire appel
à notre raison
en nous rappelant
que ce monde
va passer,
que tout ce que nous aurons
accumulé ici-bas
sera détruit
avec lui.
Et donc,
il est beaucoup plus raisonnable,
beaucoup plus logique
d'accumuler des richesses
dans les cieux
qui, eux,
sont éternels,
ne disparaîtront jamais.
Mais il n'est pas question
que de la destruction
des richesses.
Jésus-Christ
va beaucoup plus loin
lorsqu'il fait le lien
entre notre trésor,
nos richesses
et notre cœur.
Car ce qu'il dit ici,
c'est que la destinée
de notre âme
suivra celle
de notre trésor,
de ce à quoi
nous sommes
le plus attachés,
de l'objet
de nos affections
les plus profondes.
Si votre cœur
est attaché
aux richesses
que vous avez
dans ce monde,
vous serez détruits
avec elles
lorsque elles-mêmes
disparaîtront
avec ce monde.
Si au contraire
votre cœur
est attaché
au plus grand trésor
qui soit,
Jésus-Christ,
alors vous virez
éternellement
dans les nouveaux cieux
et la nouvelle terre.
Le problème,
ce n'est pas
la richesse en soi
puisque Jésus-Christ
lui-même ici
nous encourage
à amasser des trésors.
Le problème,
ce n'est même pas
d'avoir beaucoup
de trésors
sur cette terre.
Le problème
arrive lorsque
ces trésors
deviennent plus chers
à nos cœurs
que Jésus-Christ.
Si le trésor
de notre cœur
est voué
à la destruction,
nous le sommes aussi.
C'est pourquoi
examiner ce à quoi
nous sommes véritablement
le plus attachés.
Il n'y a que nous
qui pouvons répondre
à cette question
pour nous-mêmes.
C'est un très bon indicateur
pour savoir
si nous marchons
plutôt vers la vie éternelle
ou plutôt vers
la destruction éternelle.
L'enjeu
est spirituel.
Jésus-Christ
conclut cette partie
du sermon
que nous venons de lire
en disant
« Nul ne peut servir
deux maîtres,
vous ne pouvez servir
Dieu et maman. »
L'argent en soi
n'est pas mauvais non plus.
Après tout,
ce n'est que du métal,
plus ou moins précieux,
du papier,
ou même aujourd'hui
des valeurs numériques,
un code.
Mais Satan
a une telle capacité
à nous corrompre
avec les promesses
de l'argent
que Christ,
dans ses enseignements,
a personnifié l'argent
sous le nom
de maman.
Nous ne voyons pas
Jésus faire cela
avec d'autres péchés
pourtant très graves,
mais avec l'argent,
il le décrit,
il le personnifie
sous le nom
de maman.
Si nous n'y prenons
pas garde,
nous pouvons tomber
sous l'influence
de maman.
Nous pouvons nous soumettre
à maman
plutôt qu'à Dieu.
Maman est une puissante
idole
totalement opposée
à Dieu
et aucun compromis
n'est envisageable.
C'est très clair
dans ce que Jésus dit ici.
Nous devons choisir
entre servir
et aimer Dieu
ou maman.
Et bien entendu,
un seul chemin
mène à la vie éternelle,
l'autre mène
à la destruction éternelle.
Cela est tellement important
que Dieu,
pour que nous n'oublions pas
ce grand danger
lié à l'argent,
aux richesses,
a inscrit pour nous
dans sa parole
un triste exemple
de ce que produit
ce cœur double
au sein de l'Église.
Vous pourrez lire
chez vous
en acte 5,
versets 1 à 11,
le récit
d'Ananias et Saphira
qui cherchèrent
à duper Dieu,
à mentir
au Saint-Esprit
en voulant à la fois
garder l'argent
pour eux
en même temps
que de se faire voir
comme de généreux donateurs
en mentant
sur leur offrande
devant Dieu
et devant l'Église.
Ce qu'il leur est reproché ici
ce n'est même pas
de vouloir garder
de l'argent
puisque Pierre,
si je ne me trompe pas,
leur dit
vous auriez pu garder plus,
donnez moins.
Mais ce qu'il leur est reproché
c'est leur duplicité
de cœur.
Le fait d'avoir voulu
servir Dieu
et maman
et au final
ils n'ont servi
que maman
et ils en sont morts.
Voici donc
le cœur du problème
à qui avons-nous
réellement fait
allégeance ?
Qui est le vrai maître
de notre vie
qui règne
et domine
véritablement
dans notre cœur ?
À qui nos affections
les plus profondes
sont-elles réservées ?
À Dieu
ou à maman ?
Maman devient
une idole
pour nous
lorsque nous ne considérons
plus l'argent
comme un outil
au service
du royaume de Dieu
mais comme une valeur
en soi,
comme un but
en soi.
Lorsque cet argent
ou ce que nous pouvons
acquérir grâce à lui
prend la place
de ce que nous recevons
de Dieu
normalement.
Quelques exemples
l'assurance
et la sécurité.
Le psaume
52 verset 7
dit
« Voilà l'homme
qui ne prenait
point Dieu
pour protecteur
mais qui se confiait
en ses grandes richesses. »
Sommes-nous cet homme-là ?
Sur quoi est-ce que
j'assure mon lendemain ?
Sur l'épaisseur
de mon compte en banque
ou bien sur le Dieu fidèle
qui ne déçoit jamais ?
La reconnaissance
personnelle aussi.
Est-ce que j'ai besoin
de posséder
tel vêtement,
telle voiture,
telle maison
pour me sentir bien
dans ma peau
bien aux yeux des hommes
selon leurs critères
ou bien ma place
d'enfant aimé
de Dieu
me suffit-elle ?
Est-ce qu'elle me comble ?
Un troisième
et dernier exemple
« L'autonomie
et le contrôle.
Est-ce que je considère
mon argent
comme ma possession
sur laquelle Dieu
n'a aucun droit
de regard ? »
Ou bien est-ce que
je le considère
comme un prêt généreux
de Dieu
que je dois
administrer fidèlement
pour la promotion
de son royaume ?
La richesse
n'est pas mauvaise
en soi
car n'oublions pas
qu'il n'y a pas
plus riche que Dieu
et qu'il nous encourage
à nous enrichir
à plusieurs reprises
mais avec des richesses
célestes
et éternelles.
Le problème
ce n'est pas
la richesse en soi
qui nous est présentée
d'ailleurs dans la parole
tantôt comme une pierre
d'achoppement certes
mais aussi parfois
comme une grande bénédiction
de la part de Dieu.
La question c'est
de quel type de richesse
parlons-nous
et quel attachement
nous avons pour elle ?
Et si le riche
peut être aussi saint
que le pauvre
à l'image de Job
par exemple
nous sommes obligés
de reconnaître
qu'à cause de la faiblesse
de notre chair
plus de richesse
ici-bas équivaut
à plus de sources
de tentations
de tomber dans les péchés
que nous venons de citer.
Ces richesses
sont comme
un énorme aimant
qui nous attire vers la terre
plutôt que vers les cieux.
Plus nous avons
de richesses
de biens ici-bas
plus il est probable
que nous nous y attachions.
C'est logique.
Que nous nous confions
davantage en elles
qu'en Dieu.
Elles ne peuvent
que nous donner
ces richesses
une impression
momentanée
de sécurité
tant qu'elles sont là
car elles peuvent disparaître
du jour au lendemain.
Une impression momentanée
de sécurité
de pouvoir
et de contrôle.
Donc ce danger
est réel
l'enjeu est grand
encore une fois
car il s'agit
de salut de notre âme
pour qui Maman
l'idole
le dieu de l'argent
représente
une très grande menace.
Donc nous venons
de considérer
deux choses fondamentales
pour la suite
de notre étude.
La première
c'est que la source
du problème
de l'être humain
face aux richesses terrestres
quel que soit
son niveau de prospérité
d'ailleurs
c'est le manque
de dévotion sincère
et d'attachement total
envers Dieu.
C'est d'abord
et avant tout
un problème
de soumission
et d'affection
envers Dieu.
Et le deuxième
point fondamental
c'est cette très grande
menace
que Maman représente
pour notre âme
encore plus
pour le chrétien
dont le cœur
est partagé
parce que c'est lui
c'est ce cœur-là
que Maman
vient détourner
et éloigner
toujours plus de Dieu
en l'entraînant
dans un cercle vicieux.
Maintenant que la nature
de cette menace
est plus claire
pour nous
voyons à quels défis
font respectivement face
le pauvre
et le riche
pour la préservation
de leur âme
face au manque
ou à l'abondance
de richesses.
Je vous propose
tout d'abord
de considérer
les dangers
auxquels ils font face
chacun
puis la solution
que Jacques
leur donne
pour finir
par considérer
la dignité
la beauté
et la finalité
du riche
et du pauvre
au sein du peuple
de Dieu.
En réalité
c'est un sujet
qui possède
de multiples facettes.
On peut adresser
beaucoup d'exhortations
différentes
aux frères riches
et pauvres
pour leur sanctification
mais Jacques
connaît bien
le cœur humain
d'autant plus
qu'il est guidé
par le Saint-Esprit
dans la rédaction
de cette lettre
et l'unique exhortation
qu'il adresse
à chacun
de ces
chacune de ces deux personnes
pointe exactement
le danger principal
qui les guette
respectivement.
Il dit
aux frères
de basse condition
commençons par lui
qu'il se glorifie
dans son élévation.
Cela nous montre
que le principal danger
auquel fait face
le pauvre
c'est le sentiment
d'infériorité
de dévaluation
qu'il ressent
à cause de son manque
de prospérité.
Une personne
qui possède peu
voit autour d'elle
d'autres
qui possèdent
beaucoup plus qu'elle
et elle se sent inférieure
à cause de cela
et son désir
et quelque part
c'est logique
est alors
d'améliorer
sa condition matérielle
pour gagner en valeur
pour rejoindre
le niveau des autres
gagner en prestige
en gloire
aux yeux des hommes.
En tout cas
cela arrive
lorsque à nouveau
l'argent cesse
d'être un simple outil
mais que l'argent
devient notre échelle
de valeur
pour évaluer
notre propre valeur.
Si je possède peu
je vaux peu
si je possède beaucoup
je vaux beaucoup.
Cela arrive
lorsque nos yeux
ne contemplent pas
assez le ciel
mais qu'ils sont figés
sur terre
lorsque nous nous voyons
à travers le regard
des hommes
et de leurs critères
et non celui
de Dieu
et de ses critères
lorsque la dignité
infinie
que nous possédons
cachée en Jésus Christ
ne nous suffit pas
mais que nous voulons
une dignité terrestre
qui frappe les yeux
des hommes
des hommes charnels.
Le danger principal
du frère de basse condition
dans sa chair
c'est donc
de calquer sa valeur
sur son niveau
de prospérité
qui est bas
et de là
il peut être poussé
à pécher
de différentes manières.
La manière
la plus évidente
c'est le manque
de contentement.
Cet homme
n'est pas satisfait
des biens
que Dieu
a décidé
de lui accorder.
Il en veut plus
et nous ne parlons pas
ici d'une personne
qui souhaite
améliorer ses revenus
ou sa situation
pour le bien
de sa famille
par le fruit
de son travail.
Il est tout à fait
possible de faire cela
sans être animé
par le désir
d'avoir plus
par une convoitise
ou parce que nous
nous sentons inférieurs
à ceux qui sont
plus riches que nous.
Le manque de contentement
dont nous parlons ici
c'est une vraie
insatisfaction
un ressentiment
parfois même
une colère
que la personne
ressent envers Dieu
à cause de sa
modeste condition.
Pourquoi a-t-il
le droit
de posséder
tout cela
alors que moi
j'ai si peu ?
Ce n'est pas juste.
J'ai honte
Seigneur
de devoir
aller faire mes courses
dans ces enseignes
bon marché.
Je n'ose même pas
inviter des frères
et des sœurs
chez moi
parce que
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
penser de mon
modeste logement ?
Je suis misérable.
Voilà le genre
de phrases
que la chair
susurre à l'esprit
d'un frère
de basse condition
qui n'est pas
dans le contentement.
Et ce manque
de contentement
conduit généralement
à la convoitise.
Il ne s'agit plus
alors de rechercher
à améliorer
sa condition
pour des motifs légitimes
mais bien
d'une soif
insatiable
de posséder
toujours plus
pour atteindre
ce niveau de gloire
que nous pensons mériter.
Car il y aura
toujours plus riche
que nous.
Et donc
emprunter ce chemin
c'est vraiment
se lancer
dans la quête
interminable
d'une gloire personnelle
basée sur notre
seul niveau
de prospérité.
Et cette quête
finit par occuper
tellement nos pensées
et nos efforts
notre temps
qu'il ne nous en reste
plus pour prendre
soin de notre âme
que nous relégons
au second plan
alors que c'est
elle le plus important.
Manque de considération
personnelle
qui mène
à l'insatisfaction
puis à la convoitise
voilà le principal
danger
qui guette
le frère
de basse condition
qui s'évalue
selon les critères
de ce monde
à travers
le regard
des hommes
et non
les critères
de l'évangile
à travers
le regard
de Dieu.
Mais il y a
une autre manière
plus subtile
à laquelle nous pensons
moins généralement
plus insidieuse
dont un tel frère
peut pécher
non plus
en se dévaluant
à cause de son manque
de richesse
mais justement
en se glorifiant
de son manque
de richesse.
finalement
il s'agit toujours
de calquer sa valeur
sur son niveau
de prospérité
mais dans ce cas
ce n'est plus
être riche
qui vaut quelque chose
c'est être pauvre
pardon.
Certains
dans l'histoire
de l'église
ont fait
de la pauvreté
une vertu chrétienne.
Le dépouillement
pour eux
devient une marque
de piété
une manifestation
de la vraie foi
!
Et instinctivement
on pourrait se dire
que cette pauvreté
volontaire
elle est plus
biblique
que la prospérité.
Mais tout comme
il n'y a pas
de richesse
intrinsèquement
mauvaise
il n'y a pas
de pauvreté
intrinsèquement
vertueuse.
Cette pauvreté
qui est voulue
qui est recherchée
par certains
entretenus
et qui est censée
nous rendre plus sains
plus agréables
aux yeux de Dieu
ce n'est rien de plus
que de l'orgueil humain
dissimulé
sous un vernis
de fausses piétés.
La pauvreté
peut tout autant
être le résultat
du péché
que la richesse.
Certains sont pauvres
à cause de leur paresse
par exemple
qui est un péché
que la Bible
condamne très sévèrement.
D'ailleurs
n'est-il pas
assez méprisable
le pauvre
qu'il l'est manifestement
à cause de sa paresse
et qui ne fait rien
pour se sortir
de cet état
tout en exigeant
de tous
de l'aide.
Et les Français
ont besoin
d'entendre cela.
Je suis obligé
de le dire
étant moi-même français
parce que beaucoup
profitent de notre
système social généreux
pour quitter un travail
parfois pour des motifs
très discutables
parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils bénéficieront
de l'aide
du chômage
par exemple.
Mais nous ne devons
jamais oublier
que rien n'est gratuit
et que l'aide
que nous recevons
est toujours le fruit
du travail d'un autre
et en l'occurrence
de plusieurs autres.
Et que pensez-vous
qu'il se passera
si tout le monde
réfléchit de la sorte
dans une société ?
Bientôt,
il n'y aura plus
d'argent pour aider
tout ce beau monde
qui ne travaille pas.
Un tel comportement
doit être réprimé
et la Bible
le fait très clairement
en exigeant
de chacun
qu'il gagne
son propre pain.
La paresse
est un grave péché
dont la pauvreté
est la conséquence logique.
Donc,
il n'y a pas
de pauvreté
intrinsèquement
vertueuse.
Le cœur
d'un homme pauvre
peut être
tout autant,
voire plus,
attaché aux richesses
terrestres
que celui
d'un homme riche.
La pauvreté
en elle-même
ne vaut rien.
Elle n'apporte
rien d'elle-même
pour la sanctification
de notre âme.
Donc,
faire de la pauvreté
une vertu,
se vanter
de son ascétisme
est tout aussi
malsain
que de se vanter
de ses richesses.
Et c'est donc
un autre danger
pour le frère
de basse condition
de se considérer
en meilleure santé
spirituelle
que son frère
plus riche
du simple fait
de sa pauvreté.
Voyons maintenant
quels sont
les dangers
qui guettent
le riche.
A priori,
selon le témoignage
des Écritures,
la condition du riche
est plus défavorable
que celle du pauvre
quant au salut,
comme nous l'avons vu.
Jacques dit
au frère riche
que lui,
au contraire,
s'humilie
dans sa bassesse
car il passera
comme la fleur
de l'herbe.
Le soleil s'est levé
avec sa chaleur ardente,
il a desséché l'herbe,
sa fleur est tombée
et la beauté
de son aspect
a disparu.
Ainsi,
le riche
se flétrira
dans ses entreprises.
Voici une exhortation
très proverbiale
qui elle aussi
pointe très précisément
le danger principal
qui guette le riche.
Le riche est évidemment
plus concerné
par les dangers
liés à l'argent
que nous avons considéré
dans la première partie
de cette prédication
car mathématiquement,
plus on possède
de richesses,
plus on multiplie
les pierres d'achoppement,
les sources de tentation.
Mais finalement,
ce que l'argent fait
en prenant la place
de Dieu
dans notre vie,
en nous promettant
à la place de Dieu
la sécurité,
l'autonomie,
le pouvoir
et la gloire,
c'est nourrir
notre orgueil démesuré.
Si le pauvre
ne doit pas
se dévaluer
en calquant sa valeur
sur le peu de biens
qu'il possède,
le riche, lui,
ne doit pas
s'enorgueillir
en alignant sa valeur
sur les nombreux biens
qu'il possède.
Les biens terrestres
ne font la valeur
de personne.
Ceci n'est qu'une illusion
du maquillage,
un masque,
un riche
dont l'âme
est perdue
et semblable
à un cadavre
habillé en prada.
C'est peut-être stylé,
mais ça ne sert à rien.
À quoi cela sert-il
à un homme
de gagner le monde
s'il perd son âme,
dit la parole ?
Plus le riche
se confiera
en ses richesses
plutôt qu'en Dieu,
plus il aimera
ses richesses
plutôt que Jésus-Christ,
plus son trésor
sera ici-bas
et non dans les cieux,
et plus son âme
s'approchera
de la damnation
et non du salut.
Le danger principal
du riche,
c'est de s'enorgueillir
à cause de ses richesses
et de rabaisser les autres
à cause de leur pauvreté
et de même rabaisser Dieu
de par la confiance
qu'il place
plutôt en ses richesses
et non en Dieu.
Et tout comme le manque
pousse le pauvre
à la convoitise,
l'abondance
pousse le riche
à la crainte de perdre,
à l'angoisse.
Et puisque même un riche
sera toujours le pauvre
d'un autre plus riche que lui,
il est loin aussi
d'être immunisé
contre la convoitise,
au même titre
que le pauvre.
Bien au contraire,
on peut facilement observer
que même les milliardaires
dans ce monde
semblent ne jamais
être rassasiés
de biens
et d'argent,
à la fois parce que
accumuler des biens,
comme nous venons de le dire,
ne fait que nourrir
leur convoitise
et leur orgueil,
mais parce qu'il prouve
aussi par là
que toutes ces richesses
sont incapables
de les satisfaire
et d'apporter le repos
que leur âme recherche,
même inconsciemment,
comme nous l'avons vu
dimanche dernier.
Ils accumulent encore et encore
parce qu'ils pensent trouver
là le repos de leur âme
mais à chaque fois
ils sont déçus
et passent à la richesse
suivante.
On constate donc
que l'argent,
maman,
comporte des risques
différents
pour le pauvre
et le riche,
mais tout aussi dangereux
parce que dans tous les cas
ils poussent au péché,
ils détournent
les pensées du ciel
en les ramenant sur terre,
ils éteint
les affections pour Christ
en les remplaçant
par l'amour
ou le désir
pour les biens matériels.
Si maman est si puissant,
c'est parce qu'il est
un des meilleurs outils
entre les mains de Satan
pour concrétiser
son premier mensonge
du jardin d'Éden.
Nous en reviendrons
toujours à là.
Faire croire à l'homme
qu'il peut vivre
comme il veut
et obtenir
tout ce qu'il désire
par lui-même
sans Dieu.
C'est cette fausse promesse
d'indépendance
vis-à-vis de Dieu
et cette illusion
de toute puissance
qui confère à l'argent
son pouvoir
sur le cœur humain
en attisant
ce qui fait
l'essence du péché
originel,
la promesse
d'indépendance
vis-à-vis de Dieu.
Maintenant que nous avons
considéré les dangers
plus spécifiques
aux frères pauvres
et aux frères riches,
voyons donc
quel est le moyen
que ces deux chrétiens
ont à leur disposition
pour lutter
contre ces dangers
qui les concernent
et qui guettent leur âme.
Si les problèmes
sont différents
comme nous l'avons vu,
la solution,
elle,
elle est commune
et unique
pour le riche
et le pauvre.
Il s'agit
de rester constamment
au contact
de l'Évangile.
Ce qui est magnifique
avec l'Évangile,
c'est que la sagesse
de Dieu
y transparaît
avec tellement
d'évidence.
Lorsque ce message
unique est finalement
assez simple
à comprendre,
répond à toutes
les situations
en un seul mot,
en un seul nom,
Jésus-Christ.
Nous avons vu
que le pauvre
risque soit
de se dévaluer,
soit au contraire
de se glorifier
de sa pauvreté.
Eh bien,
ce n'est pas la solution.
L'appel que Jacques
lui adresse,
c'est plutôt
de se glorifier,
certes,
mais de son élévation
en Jésus-Christ.
De se souvenir
que par la grâce
de Dieu,
par le moyen
de la foi,
il a été fait
frère du Christ.
héritier de la maison
de Dieu.
Pesons chaque mot
ici.
Citoyen des cieux
et qu'il a
la vie éternelle.
Cette vie éternelle
pour laquelle
les plus riches
de notre monde
dépensent une grande
partie de leur fortune
dans l'espoir
de prolonger
leur vie sur terre
pour continuer
à vivre
dans l'illusion
qu'ils ont bâtie,
cette illusion
de toute puissance
et surtout pour
tenter d'échapper
au jugement final.
cette vie éternelle,
ce graal
que les plus riches
dans leur folie
pensent pouvoir
acquérir,
voire même créer
avec leur argent,
elle appartient
aux chrétiens
le plus pauvres
en Jésus-Christ.
L'enfant de Dieu
le plus pauvre
sur cette terre
possède infiniment plus
que le plus riche
des hommes
car Christ vit en lui
et qu'il possède
l'héritage
de la vie éternelle.
Si le frère
de basse condition
pense ne rien
valoir,
alors qu'il prêche
ses vérités
à son âme,
qu'il se souvienne
que sa valeur
n'est pas alignée
sur ses biens
inexistants,
peut-être,
mais sur la personne
de Jésus-Christ,
la plus glorieuse
et la plus riche
qui soit
et que ce même
Jésus-Christ
a décidé de faire
de cet humble frère
son temple,
malgré le fait
qu'aux yeux des hommes
et selon les standards
de ce monde,
il ne vaut rien
et n'attire pas
les regards.
N'est-ce pas ainsi
que notre Sauveur
a lui-même
vécu sur terre ?
Si le Christ
s'est revêtu
d'humilité
afin que le plus
humble des hommes
puisse devenir
son glorieux temple,
alors il est impossible
que le chrétien
le plus pauvre
se sente encore indigne
puisqu'il est glorifié
par le Fils
aux yeux de Dieu.
Quant aux riches,
nous avons vu
qu'ils risquent
de se confier
et d'aimer davantage
ses richesses
que Jésus-Christ.
Alors l'Évangile
lui rappelle
qui il est véritablement
en le mettant
à nu,
en le dépouillant
de tous ses atours
et son illusion
de gloire
et de puissance.
Je m'adresse ici
aux riches
et nous sommes obligés
de reconnaître
que dans notre pays,
ici dans cette salle,
nous le sommes
presque tous.
En tout cas,
ça ne concerne pas seulement
ce qu'on appelle
les ultra-riches,
mais beaucoup d'entre nous
sont concernés
par cette exhortation.
Toi qui es riche,
n'oublie pas
que tu es un vert
comme les autres.
C'est ce que dit la parole.
Ta vie
n'est qu'un souffle.
Tu es
comme la fleur de l'herbe
qui flétrit au soleil.
Dieu reprendra
ta vie
quand il l'entend
et les richesses
qu'il t'a gracieusement
accordées
ne changeront rien
à cela.
Tu n'es rien
sans lui
dans cette vie
et pourtant
tu t'es laissé
aveuglé
par toutes les preuves
de sa bonté
qu'il t'a donnée
et tu l'as chassé
de ton cœur
en le remplaçant
par maman
pour finir
par être
plus soumis
à maman
qu'à Dieu.
Les grâces
que Dieu t'a accordées
sont devenues
ta pierre d'achoppement.
Tu as oublié
de prendre soin
de ton âme
au point que tu risques
de la perdre.
Humilie-toi.
Rappelle-toi
qui t'a créé,
qui t'a habillé
si richement,
qui t'accorde
la vie jour après jour
pour que tu puisses
profiter de ses biens.
N'est-ce pas l'éternel ?
Et sans parler
de cette vie terrestre,
n'est-ce pas lui
qui t'a accordé
en plus de tout le reste
la repentance
et le salut
de ton âme
en sacrifiant lui
ce qu'il avait
de plus précieux
son fils Jésus-Christ
à cause de tes péchés
à toi.
Cesse donc
de te glorifier
dans tes richesses,
de regarder de haut
ceux qui n'ont rien
car c'est par un homme
semblable à eux
que tu échappes à l'enfer.
Détache ton regard
de tes trésors terrestres,
prends de la hauteur
sur ton existence.
Nu, tu es sorti
du sein de ta mère
et nu,
tu retourneras
à la terre.
Aucune richesse
ne t'accompagnera
dans la tombe.
C'est nu
que tu te présenteras
devant ton créateur
qui n'aura que faire
ce jour-là
de tes manteaux de luxe
mais seulement
du manteau de justice
de son fils bien-aimé
dont tu as intérêt
à être revêtu
ce jour-là.
Riche,
ne laisse pas
les richesses
que Dieu t'accorde
te bercer d'illusion
pour finir
par t'aveugler.
Rappelle-toi
ta condition
d'un le créateur
et le fait
que la seule vraie valeur
que tu possèdes
c'est la même
que celle que ton frère
de basse condition
possède.
C'est-à-dire
Jésus-Christ
qui vit en toi
non pas parce que
tu es riche
mais bien parce que
Dieu est riche
en miséricorde.
Voici comment
l'évangile
est la seule
et unique réponse
au danger
que représentent
les richesses
pour l'âme
du pauvre
et du riche.
L'évangile
le rappelle
qu'ils ne sont rien
par eux-mêmes
ou par leur bien
mais qu'ils ont
tout par Jésus-Christ
et qu'ils sont
tout en Jésus-Christ.
Au terme
de ces considérations
qu'en est-il
pour vous ?
Quelle est votre échelle
de valeur
sur laquelle
vous évaluez
vous
et les autres ?
Est-ce le manque
ou l'abondance
de richesses matérielles
ou bien
votre nouvelle identité
en Jésus-Christ
en tant que chrétien ?
Qu'est-ce qui procure
de la paix
à votre âme
le soir
lorsque vous vous retrouvez seul ?
Un compte en banque
bien rempli
ou l'éternel ?
Le Dieu
des armées
votre Père céleste
qui veille sur vous ?
Êtes-vous suffisamment
en paix
détachés
des biens
de ce monde
pour prendre soin
de votre âme
qui elle
contrairement à eux
vivra éternellement ?
Avez-vous le temps
ni serait-ce
que d'y penser ?
Si ce n'est pas le cas
vous connaissez
la solution.
ouvrez votre Bible
méditez encore
et encore
sur l'évangile
cet évangile
qui vous a été annoncé
que vous avez reçu
pour que vous
soyez renouvelés
dans l'appréciation
de cette nouvelle identité
que vous avez reçue
en Jésus-Christ
et dans votre zèle
à amasser des trésors
non pas ici-bas
mais dans les cieux.
Lorsque tous les frères
et sœurs d'une assemblée
quelles que soient
leurs conditions
se voient eux-mêmes
et les autres
par cette perspective
de l'évangile
alors quelque chose
de magnifique se passe
et je voudrais terminer
sur ce point
en revenant
à une implication
plus pratique
de ces versets
pour notre vie d'église
car jusqu'ici
nous avons considéré
le problème
et la solution
au niveau individuel
mais la finalité
c'est que
nous nous retrouvons tous
comme ce matin
avec nos niveaux
de vie différents
dans une église locale
et Dieu aurait pu choisir
de nous rendre
tous automatiquement riches
au moment de notre conversion
de niveler
notre niveau
de richesse
mais il a choisi
de conserver
au sein de son peuple
des niveaux de richesse
très différents
et je pense que cela
est bon pour nos âmes
qu'il en soit ainsi
et c'est ce que nous allons
considérer maintenant
pour terminer
si chaque membre
d'une église locale
applique
les conseils
que nous venons
de considérer
c'est à dire
s'il évalue
sa propre dignité
et celle des autres
à la lumière
de l'évangile
du Christ
alors il est probable
que cette église
sera saine
c'est à dire
que le pauvre
ne jalousera pas
et ne convoitera pas
le riche
et que le riche
ne dénigrera pas
le pauvre
et ne fera pas
fièrement étalage
de tous ses biens
ce que je veux dire
par là
c'est que
en préservant
notre âme
des attaques
de Satan
pour nous-mêmes
des attaques
de Satan
par les richesses
nous préservons
aussi celles
de nos frères
et sœurs
la solution
et le résultat
sont les mêmes
nous rappeler
continuellement
notre identité
et notre citoyenneté
céleste
commune
en Jésus Christ
si nous adoptons
toutes
pardon
toutes et tous
cette même échelle
de valeur
et que la dignité
de chacun
est calquée
non plus
sur la gloire
des richesses terrestres
mais sur la gloire
de Jésus Christ
alors il n'y aura
effectivement plus
ni pauvre
ni riche
dans cette église
car tous seront
égaux en dignité
par Jésus Christ
qui vit en eux
il est donc important
de me rappeler
que chaque frère
et sœur autour de moi
quelle que soit
sa condition matérielle
a la même dignité
que moi
et que tous les autres
c'est de cette manière
que le pauvre
et le riche
préserveront
leur âme
à eux
et celle
de leurs frères et sœurs
sans que les richesses
ne soient une pierre
d'achoppement
entre eux
en considérant
que le sauveur
qu'ils ont en commun
est bien plus important
et chérissable
que tous les biens
qu'ils peuvent avoir
sur cette terre
mais maintenant
que nous savons
comment nous préserver
nous-mêmes
et les uns les autres
voyons
quatre façons
dont
ces contrastes
de richesse
que Dieu a préservés
dans son église
peuvent nous enseigner
et même bénir
les uns les autres
les contrastes
de richesse
premièrement
permettent à chacun
et notamment
aux plus riches
dans une église
locale
de pratiquer
les bonnes œuvres
de travailler
à notre sanctification
nous voyons par là
que cette phrase
bien connue
est tout à fait vraie
de grands privilèges
implique
de grandes responsabilités
si Dieu nous accorde
une aisance matérielle
c'est pour nous apprendre
à en faire bénéficier
ceux qui ont moins
ceux à qui Dieu a confié
beaucoup
seront davantage
redevables
de la manière
dont ils auront
administré
ces nombreux biens
le pauvre
est un bon exemple
pour le riche
dans sa manière
de prier
et de dépendre
concrètement de Dieu
presque au jour le jour
parfois
et le riche lui
est un bon exemple
pour le pauvre
dans sa manière
d'aider
de donner
de partager
de soutenir généreusement
ceux qui ont moins
de cette manière
le riche et le pauvre
sont autant d'opportunités
de travailler mutuellement
à leur sanctification
un deuxième bénéfice
des contrastes de richesse
ils nous permettent
de rappeler à chacun
la réalité de l'existence
ils rappellent aux pauvres
que Dieu peut toujours
lui accorder la prospérité
ce qui le garde
du fatalisme
et du négativisme
et pour le riche
voir un plus pauvre
à côté de lui
lui permet de se rappeler
que Dieu peut toujours
lui reprendre
ce qu'il lui a donné
comme nous l'avons
chanté ce matin
et cela le garde
de l'orgueil
de l'insouciance
et de l'autonomie
vis-à-vis de Dieu
de cette manière là
le riche et le pauvre
cèdent mutuellement
à garder une vision
et une attitude
équilibrée dans cette vie
sur terre
un troisième bénéfice
c'est
que ces contrastes
de richesse
permettent de rappeler
de manière concrète
et visuelle
les différentes facettes
du Dieu
de notre salut
le pauvre a besoin
du riche
pour se rappeler
la générosité
de Dieu
l'opulence
du monde à venir
le riche a besoin
du pauvre
pour se rappeler
qu'il est pauvre
spirituellement
et que Jésus-Christ
lui-même
s'est revêtu
d'humilité
pour le sauver
ce que ses richesses
ne pourront jamais
faire pour lui
nous avons tous
besoin d'avoir
une compréhension
la plus juste
et complète
possible
de qui est notre sauveur
de qui est notre Dieu
et en cela
dans leurs conditions
respectives
le pauvre et le riche
cèdent mutuellement
à contempler
ces différentes facettes
de notre Dieu
et un quatrième bénéfice
de ces contrastes
de richesse
qui demeurent
dans l'église
ils nous permettent
de nous rappeler
de manière concrète
et visuelle
encore une fois
les différentes facettes
non plus de notre Dieu
mais de notre salut
le pauvre
nous rappelle
davantage
notre condition
spirituelle
sans Christ
pauvre
misérable
sans espoir
et aussi
l'humilité
de l'incarnation
du Christ
le riche
nous rappelle davantage
cette nouvelle condition
que nous avons
en Christ
et la gloire
de son règne
et de notre héritage
céleste
si le riche
est amené
à être humilié
dans sa vie
c'est bon pour lui
car cela l'empêche
de se confier
en ses richesses
d'oublier
son âme
si le pauvre
quant à lui
est amené
à être béni
et élevé
par ses frères
les plus aisés
c'est bon pour lui
parce que
ça lui rappelle
la fidélité
la générosité
et la prospérité
de son Dieu
qui l'a sauvé
par grâce
le riche aura
naturellement
plus de difficulté
à se réjouir
de sa nouvelle condition
en Christ
parce que le contraste
lui semblera moins fort
entre sa condition
de départ
et d'arrivée
et la nécessité
moins grande
le désir
de quitter ce monde
moins pressant
que pour le pauvre
et c'est pourquoi
être proche
de frères
bien plus modestes
que lui l'aidera
à se rappeler
de cela
et à entretenir
ses bons désirs
en lui
ainsi
le riche
et le pauvre
peuvent mutuellement
s'aider
à chérir davantage
la beauté
de leur salut commun
voici quelques raisons
pour lesquelles
nous pouvons aller
jusqu'à dire
qu'une église
qui a en son sein
différents niveaux sociaux
est bénéfique
pour l'âme
de ses membres
et tous ces rappels
pointent ensemble
vers la finalité commune
du pauvre
et du riche
la vie éternelle
dans la présence
du Christ
dans les nouveaux cieux
et la nouvelle terre
c'est là
que les deux
achèveront leur course
quel que soit
leur parcours terrestre
Dieu est riche
et il aime
que son peuple
le soit aussi
nous ne devons pas
oublier
que dans le nouveau monde
plus personne ne connaîtra
la privation
et la pauvreté
la richesse
et la prospérité
sont bonnes
et souhaitables
comme la santé
comme même
la beauté physique
le problème
c'est que
notre péché
nous pousse à avoir
des désirs
et des pratiques
déréglées
dans tous ces domaines
mais dans une éternité
où il n'y a que des hommes
et des femmes
rendus parfaits
par l'œuvre de Dieu
toutes ces choses
peuvent à nouveau
pleinement avoir leur place
sans que notre péché
et ses conséquences
viennent les corrompre
et c'est cela
la finalité commune
des chrétiens
pauvres
et riches
qui auront persévéré
dans la foi
jusqu'au bout
une vie de paix
une vie
de prospérité
de consolation
et de joie parfaite
auprès de leur sauveur
pour conclure
nous pouvons maintenant
répondre à notre question
initiale
en tant que chrétien
riche ou pauvre
comment préserver
notre âme
face aux richesses
de ce monde
tout d'abord
assurons-nous
qu'il n'y a pas
de dualité en nous
mais que notre cœur
est entièrement
et sincèrement
soumis à Dieu
et non à maman
n'oublions jamais
que la source du problème
que les richesses
ne font qu'accentuer
finalement
c'est un cœur
partagé entre le ciel
et le monde
ayons le bon objectif
dans notre vie
nous préparer
corps et âme
à prospérer
dans la vie éternelle
et non ici-bas
puis ne nions jamais
le vrai danger
que les richesses
représentent pour notre âme
cela nous empêchera
de manquer de vigilance
et de nous laisser
piéger par Satan
et la faiblesse
de notre chair
prêchons constamment
à notre âme
l'évangile
en lui rappelant
sa nouvelle identité
en Jésus
qui glorifie le pauvre
là où il en a besoin
qui humilie le riche
là où il en a le plus besoin
et apprenons à considérer
la dignité commune
que nous partageons tous
en Jésus Christ
en lui
il n'y a plus ni pauvre
ni riche
tous sont élevés
à la hauteur
de la dignité
du Christ ressuscité
en attendant
le retour
de notre sauveur
apprécions
ce que chacun
peut nous apprendre
à travers la condition
que Dieu a choisi
pour lui
dans l'église locale
cherchons activement
à nous bénir
matériellement
dans la vie d'église
en considérant
les besoins
et la prospérité
de chacun
en sachant
que nos biens
nous sont prêtés
par Dieu
pour nous-mêmes
certes
mais aussi
pour les autres
ne repartons pas
tête baissée
dans notre nouvelle semaine
sans examiner
notre cœur
y a-t-il de l'insatisfaction
de la convoitise
de la jalousie
en nous
ces péchés
peuvent être là
peu importe
notre niveau
de prospérité
si nous sommes pauvres
ne convoitons pas
soyons satisfaits
confiants
en Dieu
prenons plaisir
dans les richesses
spirituelles
qui nous accordent
en Christ
dès ce jour
et éternellement
si nous sommes riches
alors remercions Dieu
pour sa générosité
demandons-lui
de la sagesse
pour administrer
ses richesses
prenons garde
de ne pas être
aveuglés par elles
au point d'en oublier
notre âme
frères et sœurs
nous avons beaucoup
à gagner
à mettre en pratique
ces conseils
individuellement
et en tant qu'église
travaillons
à accumuler
des trésors
oui
mais dans les cieux
chérissons
notre vrai trésor
chérissons tous
Jésus Christ
qui nous a rendu
notre dignité
par ses œuvres
de justice
alors lorsqu'il reviendra
instaurer la nouvelle création
nous retrouverons
tous ces trésors
spirituels
et éternels
que nous aurons
accumulés
et qu'il aura gardés
pour nous
selon ses promesses
le plus grand
de tous ces trésors
étant son regard
rempli d'amour
qu'il posera sur nous
ce jour-là
je pense qu'il n'y aurait
pas de plus belle conclusion
à cette prédication
que de chanter
tous ensemble
le chant
« Ma gloire n'est pas
dans tous mes biens »
dont les paroles
résument si bien
les belles vérités
que nous venons de contempler
que ces vérités
puissent s'ancrer
encore un peu plus
en nous
alors que nous
chanterons ensemble
ce chant
pour conclure ce culte
Amen
Il a allumé le rétro